when people become successful okay they
always say I don't do that anymore what
do you mean you don't do that anymore
you should do that and then some there's
so many individuals out there that are
so talented and different things that
never accomplish anything
everyone's gonna hit adversity it's how
you deal with that adversity and the key
word is you not letting somebody else
deal with a diversity you have to deal
with a diversity need motivation watch a
top 10 with belief nation what's up at
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out under the world so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew on today's lessons from a man who
went from immigrating to the United
States from India at age four and
helping his father dispose of dead
bodies at age six to working with elite
athletes like Michael Jordan Kobe Bryant
and Dwayne Wade he's Tim Grover and
here's my take on his top ten rules a
success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be fueled by failure we're
try so hard in our lives to fit in we
try to fit into certain groups certain
frats certain sororities you know
amongst certain friends yet the people
we idolize our most are the ones that
stand out but when you're prepared there
is no fear there is no fear of failure
okay because even if you've walked out
of something and you feel like you've
failed at it your preparation is so
strong that you're gonna take that
failure and turn it into the outcome you
desire and most people stop at failure
okay we've all failed at things I'm
gonna continue to fail at stuff like
it's the most powerful tool you can use
but it all depends on how you use it you
know we talked about it in relentless
okay a scalpel
okay in the hands of an individual it
can do unbelievable damage in the hands
of a professional of a doctor it saves
lives so it's the same thing with
failure it's how you use it it's that
drive inside of you okay it's what we
talk about the dark side the dark side
is filled with failure but it's the fuel
that burns you like something that's
never burned inside you before rule
number 2 master your craft when I
started starting everyone says all
you're gonna be a gym teacher I said no
I saw my work with professional athletes
I knew what I wanted to do is I'm gonna
work with but I'm gonna work with
professional athletes so that was my
that was the goal I set in my mind and I
just said hey that that's gonna take a
place in my head that's the only thing
that I want to do and I gotta figure out
a way to I got to figure out a way to
get there so I started and learned my
craft better than anybody else did I
start with the professional athletes
Nora after I graduated I went to work in
a local health club really I knew how I
knew everything from a book standpoint
but still you gotta know how to apply it
okay so I you know worked with anybody I
could any these are not pro these aren't
pros I'm talking about housewives I'm
talking about individuals that just want
to get and just want to get in shape
people that have had injuries from
different sports kids anybody just kind
of developing programs putting
implementing what I've learned and
actually being able to apply it mm-hmm
and once I started look at that craft I
said okay now I'm starting to figure out
how to how to actually apply this stuff
and how to use it and put the formulas
together and put the workouts together
and do all these different things I mean
stuff that they're doing now from a
workout standpoint I was doing 30 years
ago I was new to you know I mean some of
this stuff is you are it's different I
stay on top of it right I got to
continue to learn you know continue to
be better myself so I can better my
athletes better my craft but it it's a
different it's just a different way of
doing the same different way of doing
the same thing right now there's a lot
more resources a lot more education a
lot more testing available back then you
kind of had to just figure it out a lot
of individuals now okay
especially in this generation not only
from a training standpoint but from a
knowledge standpoint they're jumping
from one thing to another you know
they're using this trainer this week
they're using another trainer next week
you know they're using this person as a
mentor on YouTube then they're using
this person over here okay and they're
getting all this conflicting information
okay you got a you got a master what
you're going to master okay you have to
fit you have to figure out too many
people are jumping from place to place
the place Michael
Kobe all these individuals they mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game then
they move to another aspect of the game
rule number three do it all when people
become successful okay they always say I
don't do that anymore what do you mean
you don't do that anymore you should do
that and then something mmm what do you
mean you don't do that anymore the most
successful people
No and can do it all all right you can
do it all okay Michael you know what he
never when he played he would go around
pick up the towels in the gym they have
to practice put the basketball really
put the basket put the basketball
Michael Michael Jordan Nicole we did the
same thing put the basketballs away all
right do it just do whatever when I was
supposed to do he that he packed us all
got his own game gear together you know
now people have these stylists and so
forth they put their clothes together
Michael put his own stuff together it's
just like handled its own tickets Kobe
did the same thing so it's just like hey
just because I'm now the superstar all
right I still want it I still have to do
the things that got me there because it
reminds me Wow of what I did of what it
took to get to get to this level rule
number four sharpen your mind
so if talents not enough what is there's
so many individuals out there that are
so talented in different things that
never accomplished anything okay the
world is filled with talented people you
know a lot of them yourselves
and they never accomplished anything
with talent has to come preparation has
to come action has to become development
of being able to take those talents take
those skills continue to develop them
continue to sharpen them physically
continue to sharpen them mentally
because at some point your physical
talent is going to diminish as a
professional athlete that's just a fact
okay but what keeps that competitive
edge what keeps you on top is the
ability to think and prepare mentally
over and over and over again the body
has limitations the mind does not we
focus so much on what goes on from the
neck down that we forget it all starts
from here
everything starts with if you're not
mentally ready you're never really
physically prepared and that's where the
preparation starts I firmly believe that
everybody in this room everybody on this
planet has a gift it's your job to
figure out what that gift is then it
becomes your job to decide whether
you're going to act on that or not
everyone sees the work that you put in
but it's what you don't see it's going
to determine how far you and they get I
hear stuff all the time people say oh
look in the mirror and you'll see why
you're not succeeding I don't believe
that okay it's what you don't see in the
mirror that's what's holding you back
it's what you're not willing to see is
why talent is not enough and when you
when you finally see it and accept it
and decide to work on it then you can
take that next level rule number five
start winning
everyone's gonna hit adversity yep okay
everyone's gonna hit adversity it's how
you deal with that adversity and the key
word is you not letting somebody else
deal with a diversity you have to deal
with a diversity and how you deal with
it are you gonna fight through it or are
you gonna curl up and just roll over
into the corner it's gonna pretty much
determine how the rest of your
development from a mental standpoint is
going to carry you you know people talk
about this I people talk about this all
the time you know losing builds
character okay well how much character
do you need seriously all right you
don't want to keep losing and losing hey
listen I'd rather have a person win who
has a little bit of who has a little bit
of character okay who's a little nuts
and a person that loses all the time and
he's got has got great character at some
point you got to start you got to start
winning you can't always look for other
people to help you
other people got their own problems they
got their own they got to deal with
they're trying to achieve their own
goals their will they are willing to
assist but after a while okay if you
constantly looking for a system
constantly looking for help it's it's on
you your failure and your success is on
you rule number six elevate people
around you a lot of people in business
they're successful for themselves yeah
okay or the team they put up great
numbers but the team never wins Torey
all right
you know in business when the owner or
the CEO when he wins if he's a cleaner
everybody in that business from the top
person all the way down to the last
person they all went out when sports if
you can you bring out the best out of
all your teammates you elevate not only
your teammates you eval you elevate the
equipment manner and you elevate the
equipment manager the staff the people
you have no idea the people that handle
the tickets everybody's game is elevated
because they have because the cleaners
not going to come down to your level you
got to come up to theirs rule number
seven seize every opportunity you have
to be prepared to take any and every
opportunity that's presented to you
all right nothing's just gonna happen
you know everybody say it's all on you
it is all on you there's other people
that can educate you and help you but
you take these different experiences
that you learn that stick with you I
mean you may not remember a whole lot
when you were four years old but there's
certain memories there's certain things
you can use them to either harness you
to greatness or you can use them to kind
of just keep you where you're at and
most people are just satisfied with that
there's always the next level your
definition of greatness and what you
want achieve could be totally different
than somebody else's you know we always
say no one wants to be first okay
because they're afraid of the
consequences that come with doing
something first you know we go to
Michael Jordan everyone when Michael
Jordan took over the Charlotte team that
everyone says he's a failure well how
can you be a failure when you're the
first professional athlete to own
geordie of a franchise team can't be a
failure you're the first to do something
if you're the first to do something you
can't be listed as a failure I wanted to
be the first to do something and that
was to work with high high and
professional athletes rule number eight
surround yourself with greatness so when
you choosing someone when you choose
somebody to listen to and you choose
somebody to learn from and you choose a
business partner you choose a client
they got to be as crazy and they gotta
be as tough as you are that's how you
get success that's how you know you're
gonna be able to push that individual
that's how you know that relationship is
gonna last you know people talk about in
business or think oh you got to find a
balance you got to find that person you
know if you're one way you got to find a
person that's the other way no that's
[ __ ] that's pulling you away from
how you want to do things now if you're
intense the next person I want is to be
as super intense super intense now those
people around you they got to be smarter
than you aren't right you don't want to
surround yourself with people that if
you're the smartest person in the room
you need to get more people in the room
so okay you should not walk into a room
and ever be the smartest person in there
okay the people around you have to be
much smarter or at least in certain
things you may have an expertise in one
thing but that other individual better
have an expertise that's beyond yours in
something and something else like but
from the my standpoint you know MJ was
just as tough as I was Kobe is just as
tough as I was from above from being the
best okay I wanted to be the best at
what I do they wanted to be the best at
what they do
all right it was an attraction it's an
attract and those are the people that
allow you to push them and allow them to
they understand they want to get they
want to get better you know they don't
need to be motivated okay
they're like you tell them hey we're
interesting they're not they're not
hiring you to come motivate me nobody
wanted as bad as you so what the best of
the best already wanted more than
anybody else there's a reason they're
the best you know which we talked about
this earlier at lunch they're the ones
that are show up to practice early okay
they're the ones taking the extra shots
they're the ones doing the wind sprints
at the end they're the one
you know getting treatment taking care
of the body they're showing up they're
showing up on off days you're saying
you're sending the guys home you're
saying you gotta go gotta go home you
got a little leak you gotta you got to
tell them to leave you don't have to
tell them to show up got tell them to
leave that that that's enough you know
you have people in your office you look
at it you know how many employees do you
have now
we got 4218 4200 agents okay
I had 4200 agents okay if you put them
all in all in the room okay and you were
able to put them all in one shop
together all right and say your hours
were 9:00 to 5:00 okay
you have 4200 people in here from night
from 9:00 to 5:00 o'clock from five
o'clock after five o'clock may have 500
after seven o'clock you may have 200
after nine o'clock you may have five and
then guess what at the end of they
there's gonna be one light left on maybe
to yours and somebody else's that person
is as tough as you are like but you can
count on that you can count on that
individual rule number nine my personal
favorite have intensity so we're both
workout guys we like to go to that would
you like that we like to go to the gym
all right how many times have you seen
people in the gym they spend more time
on their playlist taking pictures doing
stuff aesthetic getting their work
instead of getting the workout done so
true it's just like you know and here's
the thing all right
you're a very intense person I can tell
okay I'm a very intensive person you
apply we value our time yes okay how do
you get results in the gym
it isn't about spending two to three
hours working out people say I spent
three hours you didn't spend three out
human by time you pulled into the
parking lot that by time of change got
some black fish put your workout clothes
on talked to eight people did all that
stuff you were there for you were there
for three hours you did you could do
that you did your three hours no
intensity yeah all right all right
people talk about hey you know you post
a couple workout things you see any your
buff guy or you're next you're in a
great shape all right people say and I
want to look like I want to look like
you
they don't see what it takes to look
like you not only in the gym outside of
the gym the intensity that's there
you're in the gym and I'm assuming you
workout with music you had some
headphones on you got to get a certain
amount of stuff done in a certain amount
of time or you're in this inten stuff
somebody comes up to you
yeah and you don't want to be rude to
them see if now you take your headphones
off they ask you a question they want to
take a picture with you and recognize
you for so and so on
alright and then their questions how do
I get to look like well the one way you
get to look like me is leave me that's a
lot better and start hitting aside in
the weight start start lifting it's the
intensity that you have it has to be in
everything you do you have to be an
intense person in your workouts the way
you did the way you eat okay that's
that's intensity how do how do you fuel
up your metabolism rate so you burn in
these calories so you can get that
definition that's intent that's an
intensity how do you get to be
successful you know the old man he he or
she he's so intense no you know what
he and she that's how you're supposed to
be you're at a different level right and
that's what I said the intensity is so
it's so important it's what really
separates those individuals and you
can't get into that zone and you can't
get arms and abs like Edie or you can't
do it unless you have that intensity and
you're willing to block out the
distractions we have so much access now
to information yeah there's literally at
our fingertips
you know everything okay why are more
individuals doing less you're right
because they're easily distracted and
rule number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus rules be relentless
relentless is more than just a mindset
it's a skill set it's a mindset it's a
way to kick ass we talked about kicking
ass and taking names well when you
relentless you've kicked so much ass you
can't remember all the names because it
becomes irrelevant the name that they
remember is your name that's what
relentless is being about it's not about
others it's about yourself it's about
taking yourself to a level that all
the few people can achieve the mindset
is completely different it's about
capturing other people's hearts and not
letting them go it's learning to step on
their throat it's about killing the
competition your fiercest competitors
are cutthroat individuals all they want
to do is win and they want to win over
and over again it's not just a one-time
thing
success is repeated many many times you
can have a skill set to do a lot of
things okay you can train you can read a
manual you can do all these different
things but a skill set only works if you
have that mindset everyone talks about I
got the Hessian I got in or Drive you
know what passion in a drive is it's
absolutely nothing unless there's an
action a relentless action that follows
it and if you have that relentless
action that follows your passion that
follows that inner drive you have then
you get that end result other than that
you just have a bunch of emotions that
mean nothing
now I've got three very special Tim
Grover clips around how to make no
excuses preparation is key and make your
instincts trust you but before that I
want to know what did you learn from
this video what was the single biggest
lesson that you're going to take away
from and apply somehow to your life your
business leave it in the comments below
when you write it down it's much more
likely to actually happen so put it in
the comments below I want to see what
you have to say thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clips
sports everybody always said oh he's a
closer and they said that's the top
level of a competitor and I always
thought while working with Michael I
said comparing him to everybody else and
putting him in a category as a closer
along with all the other players
I said that's an insult I see what this
man goes through I've seen his
preparation you know I don't like to use
the word legendary with him because he's
not a legend he's an icon there's a lot
of legends out there there's only one
icon he's an icon right so when you talk
about these different individuals we
have a cooler as an individual and this
could not only be in sports it could be
in work and so forth and if you're gonna
identify these personalities as a boss
or as a director it will help your
company succeed tremendously because you
know what you can get out of these
individuals so a cooler is a person that
you give a job to and you're gonna get
the desired results you're not gonna get
anything exceptional you're not gonna
get anything outstanding you're gonna
give them something to do they're gonna
deliver a result that's expected well if
I and there's not and there's nothing
wrong with that every team and every
organization needs needs coolers on them
then when we have closers closers are a
level above that closers are people that
you give a task to you give an
assignment they're gonna deliver you
that end result majority of the time as
long as too many variables are not
thrown at them a cleaner is an
individual what we call a don't think
person they're so well prepared at what
they do they spend hours and hours of
time years of getting prepared that no
matter what's thrown at them they're
going to deliver that end result over
and over again their instincts are so
dead on that no matter what variable
what problem they could adjust on the
fly and they'll have the ability to get
themselves in what we call the zone the
problem is in order to be able to put
yourself in the zone preparation is the
key how many times have you watched
sports and they said the person's
thinking too much stop thinking stop
thinking just go out just go out and
play well
when you tell an individual to stop
thinking what's the first thing they do
they start thinking exactly do you know
how many hours and years of preparation
go into not being able to not to think
about something okay it takes years and
years and years of doing the same thing
over and over and over again okay
twice on how not to not to think Wow to
be able to take a to take a reaction
yeah and turn it into a reflex that's
what the greatest can do most people
react to things
okay the greatest it's it's an instinct
it's it's impulsive it's innate it
becomes it becomes a reflex you know we
talked about this listen trust your
instincts that's what closers do you
know what cleaners do their instincts
trust them I got this I'll give you a
great example about that it will pick up
the other thing all right Doug Collins
coach of the Bulls Shep is drawing up
this play okay last-second plays drawn
it's the Cleveland play the one he betta
you know right yeah so he's drawing up
all he's drawing up this play all this
other stuff he's over he raises it
Michaels turns around today give me the
ball get the pathway in the timeout yeah
after the time made you know before I'm
done just give me the ball get the [ __ ]
out the way okay that's that's the don't
think okay that's the point where hey
listen my instincts trust me
give me the ball just get the hell out
the way I'm winning this game hmm
I'm what in this game but that
game-winning shot wasn't made there it
was made many years before in the hill
in the dark Jim by himself with somebody
rebounding the ball whether it was me or
somebody else shooting that same shot
over and over and over and over again
say no if I get to this spot I don't
care if there's ten hands in front of me
if I get to this spot the shots going in
because I've done it over and over again
Chuck this for a second because this
just blew my mind is your dad that come
India right yes right mm-hmm and your
dad you're in the cab you just get here
you're in there yep and my mom's already
here okay so that list herself as a
nurse and well my dad it was easier for
my it was easier for my mom to get her
license here and as a nurse practitioner
that was for my dad to get his license
as a doctor hmm
all right an MD mm-hmm and he wasn't
able to get a wasn't able to get the
license we still came over we're sitting
in the cab and he's counted the money
and the meter gets to I forget what the
number was and my dad tells the cab
driver stop mmm and you're a little boy
right yeah I was four years old I said
stop and we're like what's going on mmm
and my dad goes hey listen we're a new
country I want you to enjoy the scenery
so we get out and grab all the luggage
excuse me hmm
and we're walking down the street hmm
it's a hustle you got it yeah walking
down the street with his luggage hmm and
it's showing us a different scenery and
so forth hmm never knew he didn't have
any more money in this pocket Wow Wow
amazing but he got it got you there
that's powerful you imagined that little
boy walking down that Street turns out
to be you then amazing yes so in those
scenes into you yeah and there's moments
like that that define you as long as you
remember them they can define you both
ways you can look at it and say you know
what you can use that as an excuse my
dad came to this country he didn't have
any money he never gave me anything he
never did this and people do that you
know you can look at and say he gave us
everything raise your standard Apple at
the core his core value
is that even that people your passion
can change the way people not one drop
of myself work depends on your it's
suppose to mean I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
roses success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details